[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the harry potter books the
harry potter films and none other than
neville longbottom
more specifically we're going to be
taking a look at neville's character and
uncovering a few little-known facts
about neville that only book readers
will know
that's right things that the films left
out now if you haven't read the books
then your next step should be a continue
watching this video then b by the
complete harry potter box set and get to
reading i should also mention that i've
made the same style of video for many
other characters including voldemort
mcgonagall sirius black dumbledore the
weasley family and more so if you
haven't seen those be sure to check them
out as well i'm also going to be
continuing to make them but for right
now let's focus on neville now the first
thing i want to mention is that book
neville was a fair bit different than
film neville and one big thing that
comes to mind when i think of neville's
character in the films is that he wasn't
really very well respected at least not
early on the harry potter films are
serious films they're not comedies they
don't rely on humor but that certainly
doesn't mean that they're devoid of
humor and in the films neville's
character is framed in such a way that
he is almost a form of comic relief
he's the butt of every joke and he
commands anything but respect this does
change later on as the films and his
character progresses but it's something
that i felt was worth pointing out but
neville's character wasn't just
different in the film there were also a
lot of things about him that were just
entirely left out in this video i'm
going to be highlighting 10 of those
things let's get into it number one
voldemort could have picked him over
harry if you're not particularly privy
with harry potter law then you may not
know too much about civil trollony's
prophecy
that is her infamous vision that she
foresaw while interviewing for a
position at hogwarts in dumbledore's
company it spoke of a boy that would be
born at the end of july that possessed
the power to defeat the dark lord
himself what dumbledore and sybil did
not know however was that snape who was
then a death eater was eavesdropping at
the door the entire prophecy is as
follows the one with the power to
vanquish the dark lord approaches born
to those who have thrice to find him
born as the seventh month dies and the
dark lord will mark him as his equal but
he will have power the dark lord knows
not and either must die at the hand of
the other for neither can live while the
other survives the one with the power to
vanquish the dark lord will be born as
the seventh month dies what's
interesting about snape eavesdropping is
that he did not hear the prophecy in its
entirety and only told voldemort what he
remembered furthermore young harry
potter wasn't the only boy that fit the
prophecy's criteria the prophecy
referred to a boy who was born as the
seventh month dies july and whose
parents had thrice to find him neville
and his parents ticked the same boxes as
lily james and harry but voldemort
ultimately decided to go after the
latter instead 2. augusta's respect
those who have only seen the films
probably don't know a lot about neville
and his relationship with his
grandmother augusta here's the thing
augusta was extremely proud of neville's
father frank which meant that she had
particularly high expectations from
neville even going so far as to give
neville frank's wand in the hopes that
some of his talent could be transferable
ironically this wand was actually quite
detrimental to neville anyway when it
turns out that neville isn't much like
his father augusta ends up being quite
disappointed however that all changes
when she finally discovers just how
brave he was in the battle against
voldemort and the death eaters 3.
neville's parents are alive neville's
parents aren't mentioned that often in
the films and they also sort of lead us
to believe that they had been killed by
bellatrix however book readers will know
that this is not the case in the order
of the phoenix the trio run into neville
and his grandmother at st mungo's
hospital for magical maladies and
injuries it's here that it's revealed
that neville's parents are in fact alive
but were just driven insane through
bellatrix's horrific torture in
heartbreaking fashion neville would go
and visit his parents every christmas to
spend the day with them despite them
barely recognizing
who he is
4. sat on fire at one point during the
battle of hogwarts things are looking
bleak harry is confirmed to be dead
which results in a standoff between the
remaining heroes of hogwarts and the
death eaters at this point neville
courageously steps forward an offense
for which voldemort intends to punish
him severely voldemort proceeds to stop
neville with a full body binding spell
just before placing the sorting hat on
his head and setting it on fire
this is a brutal punishment that i wish
they showed on screen fortunately
neville is able to break free
number 5. squib the longbottoms are a
talented wizarding family this put
immense pressure on neville to perform
from a very young age because he wasn't
able to produce any magic at all for
quite some time it resulted in many of
his family members believing him to be a
squib that is a wizard who can't use
magic because of this neville was put
through many tests including being hung
by his ankles out of a window and being
pushed off the end of blackpool pier oh
and did i mention that it was his great
uncle who did this to him number six
herbology one thing about neville's
character is certain he was passionate
about and had a knack for the subject of
herbology however this passion aside
after the battle of hogwarts neville
decided to pursue a career as an aura
and a gifted aura he was
but when it finally became clear to him
that being an aura wasn't his true
passion and when he was offered a
position at hogwarts in the herbology
department by now headmistress minerva
mcgonagall he accepted number seven
imperious curse in the goblet of fire
death eater barty crouch jr uses
polyjuice potion to assume the form of
aura alistair moody he does this in
order to secure a teaching position at
hogwarts where he goes on to teach
defense against the dark arts in one
particular lesson bharti crunch jr
places all of the students under the
imperius curse to see how they handle it
neville performed a series of quite
astonishing gymnastics he would
certainly not have been capable of in
his normal state 8. slug club professor
horace loghorn was the head of a club
called the slug club a prestigious club
whose members were hand-picked by
slughorn based on a few things if they
or their family were famous successful
or powerful then they were almost a
shoe-in for his club neville's parents
were known to have been two of the
bravest auras who ever lived so of
course he had an invite at slughorn's
first gathering neville can be seen
sitting at the table having supper
however in the film neville can be seen
in a follow-up gathering filling the
role of a waiter yes neville wasn't
invited back to the club but making him
a waiter was an unusual choice by
filmmakers
9. voldemort tries to recruit him during
the battle of hogwarts neville shows a
considerable amount of courage bravely
advancing towards voldemort without fear
of repercussion
in the film voldemort's response to this
is mockery he laughs at neville and
expresses that he was hoping for better
however in the book this scene is quite
different voldemort doesn't mock him he
wants to recruit him you show spirit and
bravery and you come of noble stock you
will make a very valuable death eater we
need your kind neville longbottom the
scene in the film is a complete
disservice to neville's character 10.
fluffy in the philosopher's stone we're
introduced to fluffy hagrid's monstrous
three-headed dog and an obstacle put in
place to protect nicholas flamel's
philosopher's stone one night in the
film when harry ron and hermione are
roaming the walls of hogwarts carefully
trying to avoid caretaker argus filch
they encounter fluffy for the first time
after narrowly escaping their first
encounter with fluffy the trio are
seemingly the only students aware of
fluffy's existence however this is
different in the books in the book
neville is roaming around with the trio
and this is because he's locked out of
the gryffindor tower
naturally because he was with them
neville also sees fluffy and is equally
traumatized by the gargantuan dog
harry ron and hermione have to convince
neville to keep his mouth shut and
that's it for this video if you enjoy
the content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember we're all going to keep
fighting
you